so first of all my queen how are you i'm
blessed
i'm my favorite i'm here i'm here
exactly this project is interesting
because
what was it about the sort of premise of
this or
the original that you that said to you
this is right for the small screen and
it's
right for me well it was already made
for the small screen
you know and i watched it as a kid the
original equalizer
so yeah i was like you know when it was
first presented to me i'm like well
what because you know denzel has the
movies
um i watched the original and
and so it was like no we're gonna do a
tv adaptation of it and
i said okay i love this idea
you know yeah black woman getting to be
the equalizer
yes absolutely that's that we've been
equalizing a long time this time we see
this
you know it's time to see this on on on
uh
on television so i thought it was a
great idea and then it was just really
about
you know who who's gonna
write this who's going to produce this
who's going to
uh how do we reimagine it in a way that
it works for me
that it makes sense and um that it's
believable and it feels right
and you know the idea of exacting
justice every week
come on that's not good about that
you know in a world that's so unjust
you know what i mean to be able to see
some justice on television
is important we need to like put that in
people's minds and
get people thinking about others it's as
soon as you say equalizer i mean you
said it denzel
is what you know comes to my mind uh did
you talk to him
has he has he given you any sort of
advice
i still haven't talked to d i'm actually
looking forward to his new movie this
you know
this serial killer movie that they're
they're about to put out him and
and uh romney and uh what's um
and jared leto i'm i'm looking forward
to that right now
because that's that's gonna be a
powerhouse thing right there but
um i still haven't had a chance to talk
to dee about it
but you know he's supported me my whole
career and
he's actually taught me things when we
work together
and i'm sure he supports this and it's
different from what he's doing like
uh it's completely different from you
know there's only one denzel washington
so
there it is don't expect you know what
it's like
to create the queen latifah version uh
of
of this of this character you know what
the world is like
and social when you take something that
that people have just known for so long
and you change it the way that you guys
have done it
you're gonna get the group that says
hell yes you're going to get the group
that says
hell no and then in the middle you're
going to get the curious folks
out of the gate with this show did you
make sure that you
were intimidating equalizing
ass kicking like do you settle any
questions that people have
about you in this role at the gate and
was that important
let me ask you a question do i strike
you as the type of person
that takes any
bs from
i think people know me to be a nice
person but they know me to be a nice
person that will handle that ass if i
have to
so you know i don't think i really need
to
go overboard with it you know what i
mean right
i think what you you watch the show and
you see
that you know robin mccall is gonna get
things done she's gonna handle it and i
think
i think for me you know um
that's that's that's part of the
difference as well
you know there's there's a time to take
care of business but then there's a time
to just
be you know what i mean and yeah
my character has a teenage daughter so
it's like i have to figure out how to
raise a teenage girl
and how to deal with those things and
after being a soldier and being
in the cia and handling missions
those things are normal to my character
but
coming home and dealing with like the
mood swings or
you know um first love or
you know the the pressures that a
teenage girl has to face from
drugs to sex to you know deciding who to
be in life and
choices that you make i mean those are
the challenges that that my character is
going to have to face that um
the that the original you know didn't
quite have to face
in the same way his character didn't and
uh
did and uh denzel's cap denzel's version
hasn't quite had the face in
those same ways but i still think you
see
the similarity in the the idea of
justice
and the idea of lessons that you can
teach along the way
um the cautionary tales
and also think you see how power can
corrupt
you know um and how
anybody can help someone else you know
you can just
you don't have to help in some huge way
some small
act can help make a big difference in a
person's life
i'm thinking back now to set it off and
you are now
30 years in the acting game and are you
past the point of where you learned
something about yourself
after you've completed a project and if
not what did you learn about
about you during equalizer well we're
still shooting it so i'm still learning
every day
i'm learning uh that i need a little
more self-care than i did when i
yeah my hair is still just as important
as it was when i did set it off
you know i set it off i was i didn't
that was my first real role
you know as to me my first real role as
a true
actor like i learned a lot and i was
talking about
um by my acting coach at the time
because i
i didn't go to school to be an actor
so i had to learn from someone um
who really put me through the paces and
um
he still is to this day my boy rich
lyons he's he's around me all the time
and
you know part of the thing for me is
just i've been someone who's done so
many things from
you know uh from rapping to having a
management company
um to doing a sitcom all before the age
of
you know 23. so uh
i just needed someone to sort of
separate
the various me's so that when i'm in a
role i can just
be that person and just be in those
shoes
and not worry about what's happening at
home and what's happening
uh with this business or what's what's
this project coming up or
you know i'm right here in this moment
so
i do learn something every time i play a
role because i get so
involved in that character you know i
get to be such a part of it
um that that i'm there and i never
forget
what it felt like you know when i played
bessie on hbo i was like
i remember thinking god this is
exhausting
like bessie smith must have been
exhausted
because for me to have you know to sing
all of these songs to do
live shows to have a husband to have a
lover
to be on a train like i would come home
from work
and and have to take a bath and just
soak
i'm thinking god this woman worked so
hard like this is a hard life she was
living
you know what i mean because playing
just playing it as a character and
living this and breathing this
this is tough you know what i mean i
loved it
i loved every moment of it but i thought
wow
this is tough you know what i mean so um
so yeah i do learn i learned i learned
something about every character that i
do
and i know that i i know they're
wrapping me i have to ask really really
quickly on black history month you are
for so many people the sort of example
of
you know excellence black excellence
where they look up to you you're you're
you're their person
who was that person for you when you
were young 30 years ago
starting out who was that person that
was the example that it can be done
and i want that honestly it was my
parents
yeah my parents i think my parents were
were the first ones to
be that for me and then it was my
grandparents because
my grandmother would always tell me
about her she would travel
she would tell me about how she worked
at picatinny arsenal
making bombs for the war she would tell
me these interesting stories she had
nine kids
she raised a big family my other
grandmother god blessed she's still here
um you know she raised seven
kids and so i wat and my grandfather was
in
was was a sergeant um in the in the army
and my other grandfather owned a
hardware store so i got to see
entrepreneurs around me i got to see um
the best in the worst of life the most
successful
and the and and and what happens when
you don't make the right decisions
you know in life i got to hear music uh
we had musicians in our family we had
artists in our family my mother is an
art teacher my father was a police
officer
swat tactical and and the kind of save a
lot of people you know
um so i i saw so much just in my
immediate family
that that was the beginning of it for
the beginning the seeds for me
but then i also got to see people like
diane carol
and i got to see um you know people like
uh
uh nikki j read poems by nikki giovanni
um and see art by salvador dali
and uh and the world became bigger you
know as my parents took me to the
museums
and took me to the library the newark
museum
the newark library you know and yeah
and we would just get on the staten
island ferry and go for rides
so no i didn't have a yacht but i got on
a boat and i got on water and i got to
see
the statue of liberty so my parents
started opening up the world to me at a
very very young age
showing me that there was a lot out
there and i could be anything i wanted
to be
and i like to watch jacques cousteau who
was a marine biologist so
i thought i want to study the ocean i
mean this was
it was either that or a truck driver it
was the commercial that said you want to
travel you want to make money become a
truck driver so
i wanted to either be a marine biologist
or truck driver so i think my mother
sort of started to steer me in the
you